[Music]
kevin
in bentonville arkansas kevin what's
going on man how can we help
hey fellas uh so a couple years ago i
co-signed a loan with my son's mother
because she didn't really have any
options due to her credit and um here
recently
she has been defaulting on the payments
and it's really wrecking my credit so i
was just calling to see like what
options i had available
to try and uh get my name off that and
get everything fixed up for me
oh man so let's break this down uh
one more time you cosign or they cosign
on something for yourself
i co-signed for them okay and what you
co-signed for what what is it
it's a car okay cool how much is the car
payment
uh it's about 250 a month okay 250 a
month all right
how much longer do you have how much
longer do you all have to pay on the car
uh there's about seven or eight thousand
dollars left
so not a ton but uh
because she hasn't been paying it lately
it's really takes my credit i was
uh right at about 700 and now i'm below
600.
okay all right understandable what's
your uh financial situation at right now
how much money do you make a year
uh my net last year was about 35
35 000. 35 000. okay how much money do
you have in the savings right now
uh so my savings i just wiped it out
because i just bought a house
ah okay all right so you have zero okay
yeah all right
uh so here's the thing i'm not gonna
dive into the on the deep end side of
why we teach people to not do cosigning
because
you've already done it so i don't wanna
i don't wanna feel like you we are
attacking you in this one but this is
one reason why we say do not do it
number two um right now there's nothing
you can do
you know really the only thing you can
do is make the payment
uh you signed the piece of paper saying
hey if something happened
i will make the payment so legally right
now
you need to make the payment of 250
dollars and get it caught up
uh i'm not really concerned about my
credit score what i'm concerned about is
i don't want nothing coming
uh after no one coming after me to
recoup this balance once it goes to
collection i don't want no one calling
me and my family
bugging me about someone else's car
stuff but i signed up for that
as a co-signer so with that being said
i'm going to advise you right now have a
conversation with the
individual you co-signed for get a game
plan and say hey listen i have to step
in
but everything that i do pay eventually
we're going to have to talk about okay
how am i gonna get this money back but
unfortunately right now the only thing
you can do kevin
is just step in make the payments or pay
it off but right now you're not in a
financial position
to definitely pay it off so you need to
make those payments
do you sign up for it as a co-signer
bottom line
okay so do you get that thank you yeah
you got that there is no magic
magic pill here no no silver bullet on
this one
just got to bite the bullet right and
and that's what a co-signer is right
anthony
it's the bank says i'm not going to give
her the money i'll give both of you the
money right well you're on the hook for
it then and here's the thing
and this is why i teach people um
especially like my generation are you in
my generation yeah of course i am how do
you 59 oh yeah definitely in my
generation
uh not really i'm not 59
i know you're not you're my generation
i'm 27 right definitely not 27.
but like i was saying um this is why i
teach our generation
specifically that 20 30 young 40s to
avoid co-signing everyone has good
intentions up front
okay but life does happen and the last
thing you want to do
is go into something thinking it's good
and a dream turns into a nightmare a
kind gesture turns into
a wrong gesture you have to start
thinking about your future
what you want to do and at the end of
the day you do not want to co-sign
someone being a slave to a lender right
okay and so for me no i'm not going to
co-sign for
for you john to get a car because for
one i don't believe in debt and so i'm
not going to help you do something that
i believe in right
i don't believe in and so you want to
avoid that and then let's say if i did
do that i don't want
down the road life happened to you i'm
over here living good with my wife my
kids and we're going after our future
we're building our wealth then all of a
sudden i get a call saying hey
uh john missed his payments and we're
about to repo the car and this is about
to hurt you and your situation that's
right
and so um we really have to start
thinking
that there's nothing wrong with saying
no because saying no
actually helps the individual no it's a
gift and man think of kevin's heart here
his the the the mother of his kid
needs to get from a to b yep he wants to
help out
yeah and what he's done down the road
has hurt both of them yeah right yeah
yeah yeah yeah he really has man do not
co-sign hey banks aren't your friend
right we think of banks as our friend
they're not they are trying to make
money off of you banks are banks are a
tool because we all need a bank that's
right they're not our friend
and so if a bank won't loan your buddy
money
think about it right yeah why should you
right right
right the bank has done the math and
said that probably not gonna pay us back
here's the truth i won't even loan my
friends money
no i'll give you the money or we'll walk
away if i can't if i if i cannot afford
to give it to you
then i'm not gonna i'm not gonna loan it
to you at all because i don't wanna
screw up my friendship that's exactly
right
i don't have time for that